day two of the constitutional case of
the century you don't hear that very
often but this is a case that isn't
dusty it's at the heart of our politics
who ultimately is in charge p.m. or
Parliament's and about whether Boris
Johnson misled us about why he suspended
it whether perhaps he lied
the government's lawyer Sir James Eadie
argued that suspension is something that
is in the Prime Minister's gift some
judges seem concerned though that that
might give him too much power
suppose one year but edie rejected the
idea that Parliament hadn't had enough
time to scrutinize brexit Parliament has
been considering brexit for months and
years it has had the opportunity to make
whatever legislative provision it has
wished there were lots of other options
open to Parliament a motion of
no-confidence could have been introduced
the legislative provision that was in
fact made could have been added to so as
to control the prorogation that by then
have been announced in the afternoon the
baton was passed north of the border
with s MP MP Joanna Cherry's lawyer
Aidan O'Neill defending the decision to
rule the suspension unlawful for lest we
forget this is a case embodying a
divided Kingdom within English Court
ruling for the government's and the
Scots against O'Neill's argument was
that the executive or the government was
trying to escape scrutiny by Parliament
and had Boris Johnson style firmly in
his sights we live in a parliamentary
representative democracy so the
executive Parliament Parliament is
internal accountable to the people
claiming a direct claim to the people is
not democracy populism the mother of
Parliament being shot down by the father
of lies rather than allowing lies to
triumph listen to the angels of your
better nature but his I wasn't reserved
just for the PM but even for the judges
- well not looking I'm looking sceptical
of well there's no reason to look
sceptical can look upset but the fact is
read the documentation today was the day
that politics took away
of civility here at the Supreme Court a
reminder if anyone needed to whichever
way the judges go there will be
repercussions and disruption in the
balance between the executive its when
the legislature and the court or a
disruption in the balance between
Scotland and the rest of the Union
things resume tomorrow with Sir John
Major a former Tory PM effectively suing
his successor remarkable times indeed
Louis Google Sky News at the Supreme
Court